i've been one of the main reasons that
foursomes probably won the photo play
medal of honor is because it was an
enormous hit it was the most successful
movie that ford directed since the iron
horse and
a big big box office success for the fox
film corporation so that's probably has
something to do with it people really
relate to it too i mean even now i think
people really relate to the movie it's
it's it's a sort of a saving private
ryan for its time
i i do think that four sons really holds
up as a movie uh the contemporary
reviews of the movie even pointed out
the fact that it had this kind of um
more subtle acting style than was kind
of common at that time whether this was
the influence of murnau or or what is
unclear but
i think that because the performances
are are a lot more subtle and a lot less
sort of over-the-top
uh overwrought silent film style acting
it's kind of makes the film more
accessible to modern audiences maybe i
think it's very
it seems to play really well i've
noticed whenever we've run it with or
without the score it seems to really
resonate with four suns we had a really
interesting
uh question because four sons was a film
that was released right on the
during the transition from silent to
sound pictures at fox so
it was originally shot and and and
conceived and shot as a full silent
aperture release picture and then movie
tone came along and they recorded a
movie tone track so when the movie was
released domestically it was cropped on
the left side to incorporate this new
movie tone soundtrack
internationally it was released full
silent aperture so when we went to
preserve the picture well what which
version is the right version editorially
that they're the same
but
composition-wise they're slightly
different so what we decided to do
was do both versions the the the movie
tone version from material at the museum
of modern art and the the silent version
in collaboration with the academy film
archive uh came from the the czech uh
film archive so we have two versions of
the movie now
another
huge issue with preserving silent films
is that they would have multiple
negatives there weren't intermediates
then so there would be
an a a b and sometimes a c negative so
there may be additional surviving
versions of the movie that were caught
that were made from
from uh alternate takes and so on uh
which also should be preserved you could
preserve you know six different versions
of the movie for us we preserve
everything that we know exists
so tonight we're going to screen the the
movie tone version uh of four sons which
was the version of the movie that would
have been seen in theaters originally in
1928 when it was
the
released
is slightly cropped to accommodate that
soundtrack
but this is the way that people would
have seen it in fact the soundtrack is
is a reproduction of the original uh
variable density soundtrack negative
which is also very interesting because
that was the very first
iteration of movie tone and it was used
you know for gosh almost a decade i
guess before variable area came around
you